[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est toujours du nom est
aujourd'hui
guérie de tout donner
et moi je dis avec patronat et la vivat
nallet
genton chantons noël
en choeur tous les deux nikon up du feu
louis chantant la chanson la plus part
j'entends chantons noël
qu'est la journée
[Musique]
acheminé e
et d'encombrer
de beaux cadeaux
baldo jours donnant
le diamant souvent y en a qu'un parent
s'il y en avait tu dors ribambelle
ce serait trop pour le perdant
quant à l'hiver
non
nadine touma
picado dans toute l'année c'est la plus
belle
genton chantons noël
et tous les types dans tous les pays
comme nicolas et pas 3 2
elles disent
vivre non
des friandises
et des surprises
[Musique]
non
y'a trop lentement au gré des enfants
c'est même la tête hein
le
[Musique]
chez nous nous
sans faire de poèmes pour te souhaiter
noël
on veut te dire qu'on t'aime et tu te
donner beaucoup
beaucoup de miel
joyeux noël et se met en veille
merci
je savais bien que le père noël ne
l'oublierai pas
manon que de niort
miel de lavande
dormard en miel de tilleul
de sapins que ce gentil
[Musique]
vous ont-ils pensé
non ça que j'ai pour te faire plaisir
et nous nous couchons bien vite tous les
soirs bonne nuit mes enfants me nous
fait pour un
mano à mano negra riche en bonne nuit
les petits
[Musique]
le père noël a pensé à moi patron qui
est quant à nous nous sommes heureux
patron vous re llodra joyeux noël à tous
bonne nuit
[Musique]
à